how you feeling Paul I'm feeling well
thank you oh it's bittersweet it's a
little bit of a relief but uh I
definitely learned a lot so and I guess
how much audio is is important to making
the video instead of the actual video I
mean the video is important to you
yeah definitely I learned how to
communicate better so I think I'd be
able to explain things that are a little
bit more technical in a simplistic way
I'd have to say working with the groups
and having the feedback from multiple
people I think that was a good method to
hone in on script in the video so all
the feedback was spot-on too I think the
hardest part of it was like taking a
script and trying to translate it into
different camera shots and angles and
you know how many times should change an
angle and all that stuff it's kind of
hard to do that so I took a while it was
nerve-wracking at first but I think it
was I was more nervous being camera by
myself shooting at home yeah it's kind
of weird my just been beaten out of me
um it's a that's a tough one I think
anyone who wants to I want even say
anything to do with like videography
anything like that just if you want to
learn how to describe things in a clear
way and be I don't know that's all I
said yeah there's definitely a lot of
technical oh there's a big technical
aspect to it but I'd say that's kind of
just a byproduct of actual learning
you're welcome are you nervous I'm
excited to see Aaron's videos